guys once and for all this go outside
and play [ __ ] is [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
it's not been around for a very very
very very long time everybody it's gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 296 of
the askgaryvee show and this is a very
rare occurrence I is this the second
first how many people have we ever had
on twice Casey oh wow our second segment
twice and Charlemagne the God's gonna be
very upset because I think he's booked
soon and Hugh so maybe Arielle sneaks
under Charlemagne to God to be the
second ever two-time guest of our show
thank you for having me it's great to
have you there's so much to catch up on
for everybody watching I guess three
years ago you and your buddy at the time
yeah you guys still friends you guys
yeah that's amazing um came through it
was a big show about musically and what
was going on with you two in that
platform there's been a lot of things
I've predicted that would go well you
know usually apps or things of that
nature but it makes me super happy to
have you here this morning to see
everything that's been going on with you
over the last three years and I'm sure
there's some fun little quote that the
team will pull out I have a funny
feeling that this video will be showing
up in my social media in about 18 to 24
months and now here we are the day
before your books coming out yeah I've
seen you doing some real things in music
and you know and film and TV so for me
personally and people at home let's just
I'll just set the context you broke out
on musically on that platform became one
of the most followed people you have to
see like many people transferred that
attention to other platforms and have
amassed a huge following in other places
Instagram and such but from the point
when we last saw you over the last three
years take it from okay I'm crushing it
on musically what you know how did you
get strategic about siphoning that
audience what then started happening you
know what's what's it about and then
more
what's the book about and then most
importantly for the audience watching
for all the people that are you know 9
to 99 or what I think you have an
incredible story to tell at some point
may probably not your biggest passion
right this minute but I think you can
have an enormous impact on parents and
the way they think about having their
young kids play on these platforms
because you've obviously you know so
many people want to dwell on things like
bullying and negativity but we're
spending no time or not enough time on
the fact that it fundamentally changed
the course of your life exactly and and
theoretically creates you know I don't
like how your money or your happiness
but creates generational opportunities
that you're not even thinking about nor
should at this point and that means a
lot to me and it's very big thesis of me
and mine of you know the internet and
the things built on top of them people
currently are spending all their time
worrying about it and I think that
net-net
it's creating so much opportunity and
happiness and I don't think we spend
enough time on that so that's heavy
stuff towards the end but like take me
back to three years ago what progresses
I'm so three years ago I started on an
app called musically as you know and one
thing about me is you know musically
happened by accident like it wasn't you
know I went on there for fun and it was
great but I have a knack you did that as
a normal kid it's exactly a mess but now
just what I yes you know same way you go
on Instagram and Twitter but I've been
acting and singing and like since I was
little you know my dad is musician my
mom's an actress so once I started on
musically that's okay this is great I
love it I love social media I love to
entertain and this is happening let's
see how we can use this platform and
build off of it you know I I love social
media but I would want to continue with
acting and I want to continue with
singing and I want to continue with
everything like that so um what's it
called I use social media I started
gaining doing YouTube Instagram and
everything like that met people and the
music industry started playing around
with piano and singing and you know
created some songs worked more on my
acting it took time but yeah I started
writing my book what is the book about
book is really my journal entries and my
stories and anecdotes about growing up
yep
about you know my first day of school
about self-love it talks a lot about
social media and cyberbullying and
confidence and my stories and whether
they're sad happy whatever and how I
learned from those events and how other
kids can learn from what happened to me
like my real stories and like my advice
based on what happened you know like
like things like you know your first day
of school or your first kiss or your
crush or even loving yourself and social
media and the world that social media is
right now and how we have to like stay
confident in who we are and we can't
compare ourselves to others and like my
you know my experience on social media
with being like a social media person
and having like being compared to other
people and how I got through that and
how kids whatever scale they are what
was yeah what was your biggest
insecurity hurdle like no [ __ ] for
real for real if you really like
obviously you know when you're on the
Today Show or real TV or things of that
nature you're not gonna be able to go
you're gonna have to be a little more
vanilla like on this platform exactly
but you know for the people that watch
like like to really truly make an impact
for you
what was really truly the biggest thing
you had to get oh my real insecurities I
think was my body I want to say and like
looks you know because I've always been
confident and like my personality is me
this is me like I like I'm me but I was
never so aware of the way I looked and
suddenly you know I was making music
lees and I was taking pictures myself
and nobody heard the sound of my voice
before they just saw me creating these
lip sync videos and it was all looks and
it was all like the way I was I was
never so also what 4:14 yeah so I was
never so aware of what I mean that's my
selfie yeah more importantly you're
talking about an age where you know look
this is what men and women go through
but obviously I think women go through
it earlier there's this transition we're
like and you know as a dad
young woman and like I'm sure a lot of
people can relate to this you know four
seconds ago
you're like watching YouTube making
slime or like dressing up in the living
room in five seconds later like makeup
and like whispering about boys and like
looking at your body in the mirror
that's a that repetition and whether it
have you know some people that happens
11 and 12 and some people have 16 but
whenever it happens it's big yeah for
sure and I think that's what definitely
I was you know starting musically in
this whole thing and getting looked at
at that age where I was just starting to
become comfortable with myself
so I had to learn how to be comfortable
with me while other people were learning
how to like we're learning about me and
who I was and I think that was it was
definitely the hardest challenge that's
something that I talked about and did
you spend it did you find yourself
spending or dwelling over comments about
weight or or pimples or things like you
know looking back and I remember because
I was interested in that at the time
especially for the musically stars cuz
it went so much younger yeah because
within like a lot younger a lot younger
and and for me it's all psychology and I
want to learn excuse me and I remember
thinking so what I do a lot is read
comments more so than look at comment
content excuse me and so you know you
would get thousands of comments 94% of
which were positive and great so for
sure but you know 6% still a lot and
more importantly you get 9,000 comments
if only one is negative at that age and
that affects you yeah sure and that was
I looked at like a ton of my comments
because that at the time because it
wasn't like okay you know let's build
off of musically let's build off of
Institute like it was my psychology at
that time was just oh this is fun and
like I'm gaining a following I was 14
you know like in the first few months
were just let's see what I will say let
me ask you a question because I think
this is also very important when with
parents that were in entertainment or
had entertainment skills you couldn't
have been a hundred percent like whoa
like you it had to be somewhere in the
back your mind of like wait a minute
this could be you know even at 14 if
you're always singing and dancing and
things that nature a young age you could
have been ninety-three percent human but
seven percent or two percent or nine or
thirteen percent had to be like hmm if
this really takes off maybe something
it's it's like it was weird like at the
beginning I was like it wasn't even I
was new to musically I was new to social
media period general yes you know so
this was like we had the first platform
you were on because by the time you came
and saw me we were you were talking
about Twitter being big in high school
things that nature was but was musically
a couple years earlier the first thing
you were on it was a second collection
like I think like like yeah like that's
like when I just got my iPhone for
example sounds like when I was just
being introduced and this was the
beginning was very like what is
happening and over time I think the I
want to say the third month is when we
like I remember sitting down as a family
saying okay you know we're gaining a
fall and we're like getting an Instagram
following Twitter for let's create a
YouTube channel for example let's open
up her LLC and like your website and
everything like that and so it was
pretty quick yep but those first few
weeks slash first month were just kind
of like wrapping our heads around what
is this like at the time when you were
on you were huge on musically but I
remember being excited and thought it
was funny and couldn't wait to see how
it would play out in the fact that at
high school it still wasn't like you
were completely getting mobbed by it
that some people knew hmm but I assume
because of what happened on Instagram
and YouTube after and I don't know if
you like I assume do you have to leave
school like what what's happened with
your career like do you get homeschool
did you like stay in school like what
did he do yeah so at that time it was I
was going into ninth grade yep and I got
approached for my first tour yes and the
tour was a month-long tour yep and we
like talked to the office like the
school office
it was either it really it was either
you know you stay in school and you do
social media you do continue musically
or like you know let's go for it and
that's what you do and that's what we
make sense I understand and so Oh
over the last three years of growth what
would you say has been the biggest I
open wouldn't you in at that point again
I think you want you and the fam I were
talking the family hmm
had a good understanding wasn't like
complete like you know like it was early
but there was already a lot you had a
lot of followers at that point over the
last three years what's been the biggest
surprise to you what didn't you see
happening or what played out way
different than you thought I want to say
like you know singing and acting like
truthfully and acting and this whole
when I started like for me musically in
YouTube I don't know why in my head it
wasn't as big as it was and like my like
well it's funny you say that I think I
remember telling you guys no no this is
Hollywood yeah Holly like keep doing
this and Hollywood will follow it
instead of like stop this and go like I
don't know what exactly if I see you
shaking your head like it was definitely
like no no guys this day no and I think
that was like even though like like
people like this is it this is it but I
coming to the realization of oh no this
is actually like it you know if I'm more
famous than people on TV yeah and other
places but because I'm bigger on this
platform was still hard because even
though you were young and in like still
television and film is on a pedestal
yeah and and I will say this I think
we're just at the cusp where the nine
year old you mm-hmm like whoever hurt
Susan and Tennessee is starting to be
50/50 we're an Instagram or YouTube or
or celebrity is equal to a Nickelodeon
television celebrity and then I think in
six years it will be first phone second
television mhm no a hundred percent I
think now I mean you see like some of
these like YouTube videos for example
are getting longer and longer they're
more like episodes like there's
different series is that I'm watching on
YouTube you know for example and it's
like more of this is television because
kids can look up whatever they want now
and and I apologize for coming off and
grown-ups have smart televisions
and watching a show on YouTube now is
something a 47 year old can actually
click two buttons and do exactly and
that was the big turning point like what
people don't understand is the kids are
always gonna hit like like we're always
something where kids are always gonna
adapt to the new thing very easily and
like parents are Azumi like what's this
VCR like I used to have to like help set
up a VCR or Nintendo and then that you
know but once 3270 can use that
technology it becomes the technology the
fact that Netflix and YouTube are apps
on smart phones changed everything
because now those people aren't stuck on
channels 2 through 63 exactly and I
think now with kids too it used to be
you know even with the radio and TV like
this was what like there were certain
things that were being fed to them like
this show at this time and this song on
this station at this time and I was it
we're now kids really have the control
to look up whatever they want they can
watch whatever they want but you know
what's funny right what blows me away is
that's right and yet every day I have to
talk to kids about putting out more
songs and Spotify and SoundCloud because
they're still even though they know that
that once they become the artist they
still succumb to the old machine exactly
they still want to get a a nard they
still want to get on I heart stored late
which is great but the reality is the
great thing is you literally got a
smartphone got on musically and here you
are and it is not as rare as people
think you're at a top of the heap and a
certain demo but the long tail of you
aka I'm gonna say very basic since this
is a business show yes there'll be
people who have the potential to make
seven and more figures but there are so
many people that can make fifty nine
thousand a year doing what they love
versus making fifty nine thousand
dollars a year doing something they
don't love and that is game-changing
mm-hmm Facebook I know you're watching
live please put in your questions I see
Andy carefully going through it right
now trying to find questions but put in
your phone number as well because I will
call somebody I'm sure somebody watching
right now has a child that would lose
their minds they areö and so like if you
want to like pull
at a school or oh it's actually a day
off at school this is a huge wake up
your your wake up your kid who's
probably still sleeping and give them a
shot we'll take some phone numbers
please put your phone numbers in and
reference to the comments if you if you
have your kid with you has a question
for baby RL
what what else is what talk to me one
thing that I was very excited about what
we talked off-camera after that episode
was I did see the business savvy and the
collective team you yourself is a real
young girl and and your parents and the
whole thing have you enjoyed the
business part or is this more about like
holy [ __ ] I may win a Grammy or an
Academy Award where are you in your head
I like I lead more with emotion in my
heart and I trust my gut I want to say
like I really go with who I know I am
and you know depending on what brands
want to work with me okay like Who am I
like do I genuinely want to work with
that brand because my whole Instagram my
everything I always want to be my true
authentic self and the beauty is right
and again I want to do this for the
audience it gets nice when you can get
to the top of the heap and you can pass
on things that would have made your head
spin just three years ago exactly when I
pass on speaking somewhere for $125,000
and that is more than I made what for
the whole year when I was 28 years old
there's never a time I take that for
granted I can't wrap my head around wait
a minute I just said no to go to Vegas
that's true and literally like five
minutes ago which is what it feels like
that's how much I made for the entire
year yeah that must be crazy when you're
turning out a brand deal from a water or
makeup exactly and now you would have
cried out of happiness four years ago
for a third of them huh no yeah I think
like as time goes on and as you keep
building and as I get more knowledgeable
about like this business and who I am
and who I want to be and like everything
going on I get like like you said like I
have had brand deals that I know for
years ago would have been you know the
first thing that happened to me like yep
was this brand on Instagram it was like
oh we can send you free clothing if you
post the picture and I was that was it
for me you made it yeah
this company wants to send me free
clothes and I was now if that company
offers you 200,000 fit on them like a
bead split on a you know like I mean I
get it I get it I do and listen I think
people watching or like that's crazy or
that seems ridiculous but it's like
anything else once your life gets
contextualized it becomes contextualized
like you can't you can't you can't
unwind exactly you're at what what's the
biggest thing that you haven't done yet
that you think about for the next half
decade like that gets you excited for me
like my dream I would definitely want to
put out an album and hopefully just
either being able to like direct a movie
or do another movie or produce a movie
or write I don't know just I really
going forward I feel like I have I don't
know say like not like a I have like my
base of like everything that I love and
I just want to continue learning about
each space and building off of what I am
doing and like mentally and myself wise
like just seeing what I'm able to do and
go from there kind of thing that makes
sense to me hey have you or your team
parents and things that nature have you
sniffed out though that when you go more
into the mature industries the
flexibility gets sucked out how have you
you know to me the fascinating thing and
I think you're a beak you're an example
for me you know the mute the five to
seven musically stars or youtube I think
about you you know I gave I put you in
my in my music playlist yeah so
obviously you know that was so fun when
you guys came on the show for me for a
lot of reasons because it's a moment in
time it's why I like filming and this is
will be another moment in time and you
know I'm sure when we're super old will
be little video there's fun to put mash
them all together back but I am
fascinated by the enormous freedom that
social media is and the heavy economics
brands reaching out and then going into
album land movie land where everything
is much slower yep much more restricted
have you felt any of those things as
you've gone into some mainstream stuff
you're like whoa I didn't realize it's
like have you seen that no a hundred
percent I mean I'm like like you I'm so
used to producing something and creating
a video or it wasn't me yeah if I want
to post it I can post it and it's my
image and it's Who I am this is my
Instagram and now I remember when I was
filming the movie on the first day like
I did a one-take and my initial you know
was like okay let me watch that back and
I can't even watch I can't watch that
tape back I don't know what's happening
or even with music I record and I write
I'll go into sessions and the people
that I'm working with if they don't like
a certain song for right now that songs
not coming out right now I could love a
song and if it's not right for right now
it's not right for right now whereas you
know maybe me just by myself I would
have put that song out I gotta tell you
I all my spidey senses like I'm super
fascinated by this I genuinely believe
what I'm about to say hmm the nine year
old U is just not gonna go into the
system I believe that you came in so
here's how it worked 1987 2002 people
went into the system with no control
they got picked they got lucky
the ANR's people that would go to bars
and places like picking like that's the
next Metallica and like wow that's how
you know you're in the mixed regime
which is you created it thus giving you
the leverage thus everybody wanted to
work with you but when you went into the
system you have to then work within them
yeah I think the next version is just
direct-to-consumer because what I know
is I just believe that you are more
likely to be right about the song you
love and the people in the middle
between you and the end audience because
you were a creature of producing to the
audience and the people that we work
with in mainstream are creatures of the
middle exactly
interesting stuff um okay we got
questions go ahead
you're gonna ask are you in a call
alright we're call well I'm gonna ask
you in a little bit so you give it some
thought who you think is doing
interesting stuff as people on social
media like I'm very curious what a
social media savant
winner star is seeing in the trenches of
like who they think are doing
interesting stuff this okay awesome see
what Kate has for baby I assume the book
is on Amazon now yes and have you been
in pre-order have you been waiting for
it to launch I've been pushing a little
pre-order but I know I'm waiting till
tomorrow to like just go hard
Kate don't miss your chance no come on
Kate we're really disappointed
okay we're really upset with hopefully
she hasn't answered machine we can leave
our definitely it's okay leave a message
and I'll call you back as soon as I can
thank you
at the tone please record your message
when you've finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
hey Kate it's Gary bee and baby Ariel hi
we're very sad that we missed this
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to chat
with you you're very excited and you
didn't answer that's right and we were
we were more excited of talking to you
than even the book coming out tomorrow
hey we're sorry we will never call you
back bye bye alright we'll go to the
next one while andis clean it up who is
catching your eye and so sure like who
do you think is doing interesting stuff
right now
Shane Dawson why yep um I know I don't
even want to get into what I think about
like the series and everything what he's
saying yep but I do admire that he is
putting out this different format of
YouTube that's not just deep deep deep
diving into subject exactly storytelling
exactly and just the okay with oh here's
a longer YouTube video yeah that feels
like a TV show yep I get it really
interesting format are you spending a
lot Michelle it's Gary Vaynerchuk you're
on the askgaryvee show with baby Ariel
how are you I'm great how are you Gary
I'm doing super well say hello to baby
Ariel hi hi Michelle how are you good
how are you what's your question very
well thank you do you have a question oh
my question
you caught me off guard I mean I don't
know how much we could catch up guard
you did put your phone number into I
think one of my questions was life the
life coach question you can ask anything
you want it doesn't matter what you put
into the know you have two teenage kids
on snapchat and everything and it's such
a great platform but it's such a bad
platform don't you think I mean um how
old are your kids and why do you think
it's bad yeah okay 15 17 okay
and snapchat disappears right right so
these kids are growing up in a society
of sending things out and everything
disappearing and they have no
accountability for anything that they're
doing but said well show let's talk
about this you and I grew up in a world
where everything we did disappeared
there was no documentation correct when
you went on your but everything when you
went on your phone is instantaneous no
this yours was instantaneous too when
you went in your room locked your door
and called your girlfriend on the phone
and said stuff and right it would
disappear nobody as a matter of fact it
never had the chance of appearing
everything was disappearing in the way
that we grew up right true true but I
think this is more dangerous tell me why
it's more dangerous well because I think
that they don't understand
at their age everything that they're
they're doing about well let's let's
define it are you talking about sending
each other nude pictures yeah that's
fine but I think I think what really
where you have to take this is where
does that all go right so I think couple
things one for all these nudes that
everyone's sending there's two things
that I always tell parents number one
it's remarkable in these trillions of
nudes that are being said how none of
them are showing up in other places
right number two a lot of parents call
me no Gary I'm scared if my son
you know girls mature faster than it's
really interesting I think people are
really surprised where most of my DMS
come from from parents it's more
appearance of boys worried that girls
mature faster and they don't want their
boys being spoiled and I laugh and I'm
like and I'm like I'm serious agree with
that see she agrees with that yes here's
what I always remind parents Michele I
remind them that their boys have the
internet on Safari on their phone yeah
and they are far more likely to go to
pornhub than they are to get a nude from
some girl in their class and there's a
naivete and a fear that's associated
with parenting I mean look Michele
you're your brother's if you had them or
your friends in your class
they went to 7-eleven and stole
Playboy's like boys will be boys at some
level like but shorties gonna happen 15
and 17 year-olds are gonna live through
their thing I think we as parents fear
new technologies without fully going
through them in like what's actually
happening because again our generation
were renting VHS is from the video store
and waiting for parents to leave to
watch like a porn like there's just this
extreme like demonization of new
technologies while humans are still
acting the same yes I do agree with you
to some point I just think that it's
definitely a bad platform too but you
haven't given them like you haven't
given them like I want to agree with you
if you would give me something that is
tangible saying that 15 and 17 year olds
don't fully understand is a universal
statement okay here's another here's
another one Jimmy um a friend a friend
of mine son posted a picture of the
handgun but it was really just an
airsoft gun okay and he got suspended
from school
okay go tolerance yep though but like
you didn't realize what he was doing he
was being cool I got it but but I think
a couple things but let's talk about
being suspended from school first
let's actually like play it out how
devastating or upsetting is that in the
macro for me it's a non-event in actual
life it may be embarrassing for the mom
to have to explain that to the other
moms but in the scheme of human life
being suspended from school feels
awfully minor and I can tell you 87
different stories in my school there was
something called pantsing there was a
very big thing that happened in junior
year of my high school here's what it
was about you would and people are
laughing so I guess it was universal not
just in Jersey and Aniyah pantsing in my
high school was you would walk in the
halls and people would try to pull down
your entire pants great so multiple kids
at my school got suspended for pulling
the pants down of both boys and girls
literally walking through my high school
I would see naked kids because somebody
was behind them and literally not only
and if you're really good at it you
could also get the underwear which was
extremely I'm being dead serious so so
you know so I don't know I don't have
call it their names because a lot of
people watch this [ __ ] down but like
people got suspended in high school for
pantsing a girl in the middle of the
whole school that's also embarrassing
that wasn't snapchat snapchats not
dangerous kids are doing dumb [ __ ] from
13 to 20 because that's the evolution of
a human that's where I would go with it
I don't think snapchat is the problem in
the scenario of kid putting up you know
a foam gun I think kids do dumb [ __ ] and
they play out digitally or in real life
I would ask parents across America
what's worse
Foam gun on snapchat by the way in
today's environment so identity or yeah
boy pulling down girl's pants catches
underwear and she's naked in front of
the entire school both feel pretty
difficult to be palpable what I'm saying
is do much dumb [ __ ] kids are doing in
real life and you have no idea they're
doing it because it's not being
documented we need to run on sound never
say not my kid either because you guys
never know it could be my kid tomorrow
yeah it depends on the person really
it's not really I don't think it's the
that like snapchat or and so they could
post whatever they want on Instagram
they closed whatever they want out
they've I mean kids have like fences now
where they only accept you know ten kids
and they're posting tons of different
kinds of pictures I think it really
depends on the person and what they're
taught like for my for me and my parents
for example they always for instance
when I first got a phone they said
whatever you put out there is out there
forever whether it's on social media or
even in real life whatever you say to
someone it's like it depends on the
person and I think what they're taught
and what you taught your kids and if you
trust your kids I mean I'm not a parent
look look I think I'm so glad you called
because there's so many interesting
conversations here number one yeah what
does society accept let me talk about my
career nine years ago I started putting
out business videos on the Internet
I was scold if you go look at the
comments I was scolded Michelle scolded
for cursing like it was completely
unacceptable in in so many people's eyes
now it is just so much mine more minor
to most people's eyes than it was just
ten years ago so I think the other thing
is who's the judge in the jury like I am
super duper not concerned about my child
being suspended from school cuz I'm
because I disrespect the institution of
a high school and I think things I think
things evolve I think the question is
intent and who's the kid really in the
scheme of things because I think this
Michelle I think you and I can both
agree both of us did some dumb [ __ ] in
high school sure everybody does and if
they say that they didn't they're lying
that's exactly right so I think what
parents have to reconcile if I think
most parents are actually more worried
about the judgment of other parents
because they know their kid and they
know if they're a good kid or a troubled
kid one way or the other of how it all
plays out do you know what I mean I do
because I tell my kids I don't care what
everybody else thinks I only care about
oh you two and what I think that's that
I really don't care about other people's
judgment but I'm just saying
as kids too in a society they're being
looked at I mean you know girls send new
photos
it's like someone pulling down you it's
not the same as someone pulling down
your pants but you're you're allowing
yourself to show the world everything
listen and I gray and listen no parent
wants to have the visual of their young
daughter sending nude photos to somebody
else
I have unbelievable amounts of empathy
for that I think what I'm most
fascinated by oh and this is super
philosophical which i think is always
dangerous because when these things
become real to people they're like
that's cute Gary that you're talking
about empowerment in an 80-year window
around how social media plays out
I now have today a 17 year old girl and
I'm worried about this so first I made a
rule a long time ago about like getting
into people's business
not their marriages not the way they
raise children but I will say this
demonizing platforms that are exposing
you not changing you is something I
think parents need to be more thoughtful
of in 2018 right because because it's
not great it's not snapchat like like no
it's not snapchat it's just a platform
that they're using to do the thing
that's right but then the best shot the
question is why are they doing these
things for example I ripped apart how a
mother popularity yeah well uh or
something else I ripped apart a mother
privately who I'm an acquaintance with
who got very upset about my points of
view on social media and things of that
nature and I was eating it but I was
sitting on something and just to like
play it out basically I told her and not
so many words maybe if you didn't keep
telling your daughter when she was 8 9
13 and 14 to get skinnier maybe she
would have hit her self body image and
maybe she wouldn't have played out that
way so parents love to blame social
media and they love to blame other kids
but they're not paying attention when
they snap at their daughter when they're
11 and they're eating a cupcake and
they're reinforcing to their daughter
that that mother has judgment on that
girl's body type correct
so like all right I think there's a
unbelievable lack of responsibility by
parents right now then you know there's
a lot going on and I just think a lot of
parents don't want to take on
accountability for what they're doing
I'm right Michelle you know this your
new trend
though they don't they absolutely don't
want to take on accountability they turn
the other eye that's right the other way
social media has been the punching bag
current punching bag of parents who
don't want to take accountability for
the fact that they did not raise their
kids with enough self-esteem to be able
to navigate in today's world the end
right oh and by the way Michelle let me
give you a counter-argument real quick
cuz this is turned into a very important
conversation what about how much more to
talk yeah this is a perfect talk well
what's funny is we went one down one
route I gave you the example of mom
making daughter insecure thus daughter's
looking for positive reinforcement
where's she gonna get it from going
scandalous to fifteen-year-old boy who
gives her positive reinforcement let me
go the other way the other thing that
parents have to recognize is if you tell
your kid that they're great at
everything when they suck at singing or
when you give them a ninth place trophy
for tennis and make them okay with them
when everyone gets trophies when they
get to 15 17 19 22 in the world kind of
takes over and they're out of the
parents bubble and they're like wait a
minute and I'm not the best and my
parents taught me that adversity is bad
all of a sudden they're crippled by
adversity and they act out in a
different way this is a very this is a
very important for parents to step up
parents are becoming more removed and
selfish about their own lives than ever
because parents are younger than ever
and they want to still keep on living
and so what they're doing is they're
pointing fingers at social media
platforms and it's a very important
subject that we need to talk about more
it is extremely important and this is
surface talk and you ever want to talk
about it again I have so much to say
about it we'll get well before listen
we're here and we're here right now yeah
like like and honestly I think it's
important because look baby Ariel here
sell some [ __ ] books and I will tell
you that knowing where she went with
this book this is a book that I think
parents and kids both need to read
because it's gonna give them insight
while weave I want it I've been talking
a lot because I'm very passionate about
this I'm gonna I want baby Ariel to talk
about the DMZ he's getting from 13 14 15
year old girls and what they're saying
about their parents I'm gonna let her do
that but I'm not gonna I'm gonna let you
say something in Michelle give me you
just said you have something else to say
give me another data point of things
that you find fascinating oh well I'm
just referring to this I'm recently
divorced and I'm now I'm at
my life where I have to try to rebuild
my life and and then make something for
myself because in just a few years my
kids are often on their own but yet it's
this this push and pull because I don't
want to give up my kiss and like let's
say usually word abandon that's not the
right word abandonment but I still need
to rebuild my life so yet we'll continue
to guide them to make sure that they're
making the right choices in their future
I can't you know just walk away but
there's got to be a balance there that's
the dough between your cook that's such
a good point between what you have to do
professionally the fact that you have to
now play in a new personal environment
and you need to be happy before you can
any bring any happiness to your kids I
mean to your point right all these
things are so circumstantial I love when
people like point at other people and
say they wish they were them and I'm
like yeah but tomorrow that person could
become terminally ill like nobody rose
anybody's details and that's such a good
point to me the new that is my friends
laugh at me they laugh at me because
I've become a stair climber where I
climb the World Trade Center by the time
Empire State Building I just applied for
the lottery for the Eiffel Tower but
then I'm like a hot-air ballooning in
the Macy's Day Parade and carrying
holding onto one of those balloons and
the Macy's Day Parade and you know and
i'm taiking i'm doing all these things
and my kids are like wow mom that's so
inspiring and i'd like told them along
with me to like do these out-of-the-box
type of things because i think it's
really important not to be pigeonholed
them to everything but i want to hear
about the book instead of the book for a
second cuz we'll close with that tell me
and tell everybody's watching who have
no [ __ ] idea because 14 year old
sally is sending you messages they're
not walking to their mom's room and
saying let me tell you everything okay
what are the common themes when you read
stuff about what kids are saying about
their parents I mean it's a lot of I
think right now kids a lot of pressure
that they're getting from their parents
to a lot of comparing their kids to
other children based on what they see I
think parents are now on social media
more and they see other kids they go on
Facebook and they see Stacie's kid in
this person's kid and a lot of
comparisons between okay why aren't you
more like
this person for this kid they being not
comfortable with themselves they go on
social media and to find this you know
their comfort which I don't think is
right and they compare themselves again
to another kid they compare themselves
to every social media every magazine
model every single person on social
media and they're already getting their
that pressure from their parents and
they're already getting the what's
called the comparison from their parents
and now they're doing it to themselves
which I don't think is right of course I
think you to go on social media one
thing I learned is you have to be
comfortable with yourself first and you
have to be comfortable enough to put
yourself out there as who you truly are
or else the comments will get to you and
I think also with more parents just in
terms of school they feel a lot of just
pressure when it comes to school when it
comes to why aren't you doing football
or why aren't you doing this why aren't
you doing that why aren't you starting
your own whatever because they see all
these other kids doing certain things
right and what's really interesting is
they see all these other kids and people
haven't quantified it there are a couple
thousand kids breaking out and there's
tens if not hundreds of millions of kids
mm-hmm so like people are comparing
themselves to the point one percent they
don't understand the talent that is
involved we've quantified the talent of
being LeBron James we have not yet
quantified the talent of being baby
Arial we haven't exactly like just to
give you a nice like compliment like we
are not in a stage yet where we
understand being an influencer and being
a travel blogger
is work and talent huh and now because
of the way I think a lot of social media
influencers present themselves is oh
here's my everyday life and here is me
blah blah blah this is what I'm doing
and parents don't understand why their
kid can't do that for exam and kids
don't understand why they can't do that
exactly they see it's just being
ourselves yeah they think they're gonna
go outside take a picture of their first
Instagram put a really rad feel
Ronit add a couple key words and four
minutes later you know you know nerds
candy is gonna give them 50,000 bucks
exactly Michelle thank you for calling
good luck with everything
thank you can't wait to see Michelle on
the Macy's Day Parade let's stick in one
more phone call what haven't we touched
on with the book and pick up the book
and support baby Ariel what haven't we
touched on the book that you think might
bring value who is the target reader for
you or who is somebody who might get
value from this that maybe people aren't
thinking about um let me think how young
do you think this book can go let's go
there I want to say what you've got tell
you nine eight around because it's not I
have a lot of stories and they're about
me it's but I think people can take
those stories and they can see what I
was feeling in that time and relate to
what I was feeling you know it's not
just about self-love but it's also about
school and you know your family for
example and like family problems that I
have you know about my grandparents and
about dealing with friends and friend
breakups you know when somebody isn't
being nice to you and you love boy
relationships Oh a hundred percent about
like this boy who wasn't treating me
well and I think kids now are getting
into relationships younger and they can
relate to you know friends being mean to
them and boys not treating them but
treating them well and they can read
this book and understand okay it's not I
want them to read this book and know
that it's not just you're going out of
it exactly then they can because I don't
think a lot of kids now because of
social media they are the ice let the
isolate themselves more and they're more
into their phones in their YouTube and
they watch a lot more and they're on
their foot and when they're not
interacting with other people the good
news this no guys like I'm 42 years old
like people went in the room locked the
door watched MTV and played Nintendo all
day like I don't understand this Nirvana
like I'm there unless you're 90 [ __ ]
years old
there is no Nirvana that kids went out
side and played all day and like Leave
It to Beaver was a hundred [ __ ] years
ago like this notion that these parents
of you I remembered my favorite part of
when you came out which was like oh [ __ ]
cuz even earlier I was like us and I was
talking like you and me are the same my
parents were like younger than me like
to me this notion if you're a parent of
a nine to twenty year old [ __ ] you and I
mean this this notion that you lived in
this world where everybody went outside
like let me tell you about the 80s no
kid went outside because that's when
kidnappings started and America's Most
Wanted started and everybody stayed
inside what the hell do you think
happened with MTV people to wave phones
phone lines for girls like video games
came out in the 80s like guys once and
for all this go outside and play [ __ ] is
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's not been
around for a very very very very long
time it's a long time since boys played
stick boy stickball in Brooklyn we're
talking about a time a long time ago the
social media demonization is laughable
it was called the television it here's
what people did in 1984 they went in the
room they watch TV they played video
games and you know what Instagram is
it's Seventeen magazine and Vogue they
went through magazines over and you know
what you're [ __ ] explore feature is
on Instagram and your newsfeed is it's a
magazine you know what's better about
this magazine than the one I grew up
with the pictures change because you
would look at the same source and Sports
Illustrated and and all the dogs I mean
it is time for us to put this to bed
they're like this world that parents
have made up in their head that is their
Gramp you a 49 year old parent you
didn't live this world your parents did
you've now made pretend because you're
scared because you love your kids so
much that you can't breathe unless you
go fearful mm-hmm but I mean enough of
this like isolation kids were isolated
guys the [ __ ] do you think runs rock was
you know what happened in [ __ ] 1989
and 90
kids did was listen to the pressing [ __ ]
go listen to Kurt Cobain go listen to
[ __ ] black holes son like what does
it matter with everybody here kids are
always isolated they've been isolated
the hell do you think the Beatles were
like what do you think is going on this
notion that anything's changed KITT when
you are ten thirty when you are thirteen
to twenty a lot happens the end and what
I'll tell you is here's what's changed
parents are either micromanaging their
kids too much or not paying attention to
them too much
we've lost balance at the parent level
out of selfishness from parents and they
want to blame [ __ ] snapchat and an
Instagram we need accountability on
parents to get out of their kids
business or get it into their kids
business because there's no [ __ ]
balance period that's the truth baby
area yeah good Robert I totally agree
with it my daughter is 11 turning 12 and
she's very well known actually through
me through social media because I've had
her on live streaming and other things
and she's really building on the old
musically and I'm listening keep going
oh okay I saw the arm go across like
don't keep doing music the arms the arms
the arms up
you're on delay on video keep talking
we're live here baby turn down your turn
down the audio
I'm till I stop watching a video it's on
delay and go ahead so building on
musically which baby are you and you
probably know is now hold a sock yes and
they seem to be changing a lot of things
but I don't know if you're finding that
also that she he was building strong
really fast she's up to 1,100 followers
and for her trying to build her YouTube
channel I mean you know she started it
last year and she's a thing like the
area in fact she's excited to see you
tomorrow night in Livingston yes
I'm excited to see her tell her yes I
will I will tell Rayna to say hi hi Rena
oh but you know what is finding the
struggles now because I don't know if
you've seen it Gary that the pops are
now starting to hit on musically where
they do the light box the box where they
do a follow and then they unfollow yeah
see four numbers go up and down up and
down all the time brother let me tell
you something right now I'm gonna cut
you off I apologize you have to at all
costs sit her down
day after day hour after hour and tell
her and you have to eliminate her having
any validation by engagement numbers or
following count because if you allow her
to care about it it's game over
yep brother I promise you with all my
heart I want you guys to win finding
validation from how many people follow
you or how many people like your posts
is the is the death trap of this game I
think that for me being someone on
social media that was one of the hardest
hurdles that I had to get over you know
it used to be where I would go online
and look for sometimes myself love and
my confidence in the likes that I was
getting and sometimes they would go down
sometimes they would go up and you I'm
telling you right now as someone who did
care and has someone who got down on
myself because of the likes and the
numbers you have to tell her that that
does not matter cuz it goes in the waves
and it summer happens for example kids
are on their phones more the likes will
go up school starts the likes will go
down because they're at school more
midterms are happening to likes well
it's goes in so many diamond mines on
the waves and let me jump in here the
thing that really scares me brother
especially for an 11 12 year old girl
what why you have to not allow them to
be validated by this engagement is when
they get sucked in and by the way 99% of
people from the ages of 9 to 99 are
suckered by this I'm telling you I would
argue that this has been the single
biggest reason that I've been happy and
successful that I never was because I
knew that they were just a proxy and and
and gamified and all this dirty
stuff engagement group all the horseshit
here's what you're really gonna worry
about if she if she starts worrying
about engagement numbers and following
it's gonna lead her to doing things like
showing more skin being more like you're
gonna go to lowest common denominator
things you know and then that's like
cliche girl stuff
forget about even that both girls and
boys you're gonna go into things that
are pandering for likes and you're gonna
limit your creativity
I get excited my team will tell you I
get excited when we do poorly in
engagement because I know we took a
creative risk or did something new and
we learned from it it's like science the
noes are sometimes better than the yeses
but when you're self esteems wrapped
into it you become one-dimensional and
all of a sudden I get these DMS all the
time like like 31 year old women saying
like Gary I can't grow my account unless
I show my ass and I'm like don't kill
your [ __ ] ass unless you're in the
showing ass business like like you have
to I'm telling you right now the reason
I don't care about BOTS or anything else
they don't matter to me because that is
not the currency the currency is loving
the process of what you're doing and
then what are you actually trying to
accomplish with all the attention and
following are you building a business
are you trying to become a known expert
in a field like what are you trying to
do with it its depth versus with you
have to brother right now off this phone
call you have to and not in dad way of
like hey daughter don't care about the
likes and and followers no no way deeper
of like let me tell you why the likes
and followers don't matter because what
we're actually trying to accomplish if
you want to be a singer it's not gonna
be people get signed with 5,000
followers Justin Bieber only had 60,000
views on YouTube when scooters signed
him on his posts so like it comes in all
shapes and sizes
but you will lose the self-esteem game
if you value yourself based on likes and
follows and unfortunately 99% of people
do mm-hmm
one thing that really helped me when I
was you know just starting and my
parents and I actually did this like
pretty much every year is when I or even
when I'm low on myself
we'll sit down with a huge piece of
paper and write down a game plan and my
goals and what I want to work on what
what I want to get better and my
demographic Who am I trying to reach and
what am I trying to do like do I want
the numbers or do I want five people
let's pretend five people and I want to
make those five people happy because
everything will come organically and
it's going to happen if you just have to
remain true and also I don't want her
make sure I don't want her to go online
and get deeper into this hole of finding
her validation on social media just like
just tell if she needs a break from
social media that's fine or you're seven
yeah right so let's use B we are ELQ
she's right here clearly her content is
gonna be different
she's 17 she's baby Arial let's play it
out clearly her posts are gonna be
different if she's looking for attention
from boys and wants to like go that
route versus she wants to be a dominant
player for twelve-year-old girls it's
not super complicated and we've seen it
with Nickelodeon stars over and over and
over again they start their careers
they're of a certain mindset and age and
ambition professionally and they crush
it for eight to thirteen year old girls
and then after scratching that itch or
achieving their goals and they're 17 or
18 they want to then get attention from
boys and you can see the transformation
happen in your eyes like literally black
and white and so what's important about
that just to use her as an example is
your content needs to speak for what
you're trying to achieve and so and
those things that you're trying to
achieve change over time and the cliche
thing is you go for that audience then
you go for it you know let's just play
it out you go for those teeny bopper
girls then you go for boys then you go
back for the teeny bopper girls like you
see it over and over again the bottom
line is everybody's actions will play
out in their posts you have to watch
them carefully I don't need to like have
every access to my kids accounts what
they put out publicly and I have a big
advantage
I knew about Finster Graham I wanted
literally you know Finster
was like first it was called Finster
Graham five years ago now it's gained a
lot of popularity because kids have
to snapchat and Soph insta matters more
because really they used snapchat as fin
stuff exactly and so it's like really
fun to watch it all evolve here's what I
know kids are always gonna hide from
parents and that's healthy that's
healthy
you just have to instill the right
virtues and I promise you brother you
allowing your daughter to care about
followers and likes is a very very
vulnerable place and you need to get out
of that ASAP okay no I try to tell her
it doesn't matter all the time but it's
hard at that age no [ __ ] but guess what
yeah you have to be right you a be
religious about it and and you calling
this show and asking about the bops on
musically means that you're further into
it then you should be from my
perspective I could be wrong you raised
your daughter the way you want to but I
want you to win and I like your vibe and
I'm telling you that is the line in the
sand [ __ ] I brought it up only because
that's what I do
similar to use social media for a living
I got I know about the bots great ready
let's get rid of the kids it's now me
and you and talking about our careers
[ __ ] the numbers oh I don't care about
the numbers at all good then [ __ ] BOTS
yeah yes I personally don't but it's
trying to explain it to an 11 year old
sometimes and you know because she's got
that preteen there's times I feel like
I'm talking to a 30 year old girl and
many people if they're watching Friends
of this she's 18 months that's right
exactly I get a present between stage I
get a brother good luck man thank you
final thoughts Ariel by the way are you
ever gonna drop the baby part I've been
thinking I got this and yeah I was like
this was something I wanted to ask oh
she's gonna be like those rappers that
have to drop like the prefix like you
know how like I'm trying to think who's
a good one like there hasn't been a
bunch but yeah bow out you know like
like you know like you know it's just
fun when people have to drop like the
lil or the thing you know the best have
you thought about dropping it or do you
want to go the other way and just own it
in perpetuity my I think I'm gonna just
own it
well I mean licked honestly like right
now it's Who I am it's working like
there's no and unless there's a real
reason like okay I agree like if it's
working it's working more importantly
like there's nothing wrong with it I was
just super curious if it's run through
your mind I mean it has for sure because
I'm almost 18 and okay like I've been on
a baby yeah but I mean what's good about
baby it's not like it's like kind of
like Lille right like you can kind of
like that's an effect I actually think
maybe you should go deeper into it
so that every kid coming up uses baby
the way everyone use Lille yes right
there has to be a bunch of nine-year-old
girls named like baby Saturday I saw
like a few like Instagram kids on like
you know and their name was like exactly
yeah and I'll say okay if we can make it
a thing like let's just make it a thing
I remember a couple people did the two
silent E's in business cuz I did it with
Gary Vee and I literally DM them like no
no no I'm like that was a huge mistake
of mine silent silence mouths are like
terrible like like get out of it like so
anyway it's really great to have you
what's your question of the day guests
get to ask the question day what's your
question for the vaynernation oh I guess
what are you passionate about and what
do you want to what do you dream about
what do you want to perceive and what's
your passion you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them
[Music]